and i was just trying to write in my
book
and i'm just shaking and you can't get
over it ptsd on the spot
no yo what were you saying guys whoa
what are we saying man what are we
saying
j money in the cup where you go in the
car as per usual you know the vibes you
know
monday and um we're ready to boogie gee
i'm excited so
as usual guys hop on that patreon
two episodes every month first and the
15th
yeah man run me my p ah three pound a
month
juicy tempe a day it's uncensored it's
fantastic content
it is funny as we get into gruesome uh
conversations topics have been very
sexual as of late
um if i'm honest but yeah they've been
doing it man i've been having a good
time
uh with it and um again as always
jump in and grab the new merch as young
fueg is sporting today
um you know the vibes always like the
video leave a nice comment
um leave a nice review if you're an
audio listener
and um like it as well man let's run up
the algorithm on youtube like like our
[ __ ] man
we've got yeah youtube's been working
against us as i'm like
youtube's officially decided they're not
going to pay us any money anymore
they've had enough of us they've had
enough of our antics
and um they've decided that they're not
going to pay us anymore so that's fine
just keep liking them so yeah let's um
let's get spread the word and
get s g global so they can't ignore us
they can't ignore us and they have to
pay us
so they have to pay us we're already
second biggest pokers in the world
exactly clearly that's not enough
it's not we have to be i don't know what
more they want from us but clearly all
right bet
you want to play that game challenge
accepted it's fine just come on
no you don't want to face anyone lock
down the whole show
that's when they take us off just a
quick message checkmate
i'd have to go to california that day
was squaring up me and youtube was great
we'd have to maybe have to screw up
you'd have to square up
um but yeah guys anyway let's um jump in
with a fun fact
yeah and get the ball rolling man also
guys if you guys have any fun facts that
you want to give me
so i can oh that's good yeah i'd like
yeah i'd like to
find inserted fun facts yeah just send
them my way and then yeah man
because i've had a few that i've done on
here before that
sent from fans and they're actually like
oh wow these are actually good facts so
yeah
and you learn every day um do you know
what the first game was that
allowed you to save your progress in the
game
um the first game that allowed you to
save your progress in the game
zelda oh my god yes was actually legend
of zelda 1986
gang wow gang wow gang wow
normal miner that's how my brain works g
wow zelda yeah i don't know why i need
well i say i don't know why i knew that
i don't know it guess complete yes
that's a very good guess though
yeah that was the fun fact yeah sick
there you go there you go guys
if you didn't know now you know clearly
he knew and clearly obviously some other
people knew as well that's sick
yeah that makes sense man i don't know
why a zelda is a heavy game
um i have nothing to follow up i don't
know i wish i could be like yeah i know
it's older because of this
this is just really a good guess damn
stumped me
i've got a question for you though that
stumped me i was like oh where do i go
from here
but i've actually got a question for you
then this was from a fan as well
obviously we do quite a few i'll say
quite a few but we've done a couple
would you rather's on our instagram page
if you don't follow us on instagram
please follow us on instagram and you
can get more interactive with us
and a fan said this to me but i didn't
put it up on the on
instagram so it's good opportunity for
me to say it now would you rather
be able to play any instrument in the
world or be able to speak any language
in the world at your choosing
oh or let's say every instrument in the
world or ever learn every know every
language so i either can play
you can play all these everything or you
can speak all the languages all the
languages
no no qualms no hassle it doesn't [ __ ]
with your memory or your brain or
anything
i think i'll go languages why couple
reasons
firstly which is a really boring reason
firstly
i feel like learning because i've always
decided like when i get to finally buy a
big house
i'm gonna convert the garage into like
my own
space okay and i'm gonna hav i'm gonna
like uh sound proof it
and have a drum kit in there and i'm
gonna learn how to play the drums okay
but i'm more looking forward to the
actual learning of playing the drums
than i am at being sick at the drums
makes sense so
that's something i'm actually that's a
part of my life that i'm really looking
forward to doing
okay whereas i will never know languages
because i can't be bothered to learn
them
it doesn't seem fun for me and when we
were learning spanish
what we did it for two three years none
of it was fun for me i didn't enjoy
learning it one bit do you know what i
mean it wasn't fun at all
yeah i just did it and um so
i'll pick the languages firstly for that
point and secondly
i have a real like my how do you say it
my choice of like vacationing is always
limited because
based on where i think people will or
will not know english
because like for example japan i want to
go to japan
and i want to do up japan yeah yeah i
want to do tokyo i want to go to like
the outskirts of japan i want to i want
to see rice paddies i want to see the
lot you know what i mean
and i want to really get it but i don't
want to go places where people no one
understands what i'm what i'm speaking
yeah because i'm just not that socially
like
guide to just like oh [ __ ] the language
barrier i'll just do it anyway yeah i'm
just not that guy
that makes it a total sense big on
convenience okay
it has to be convenient for me if it's
extremely inconvenient i'm just
i will never have the energy to do it so
it's like learning having every language
would just be
i would just travel travel travel and
just do [ __ ]
all the only literally the only thing
that stops me half the time is is the
language barrier okay
because it's just like i don't want to
do this like i remember
um i told you before my mom took us to
morocco when we were kids yeah and the
part of morocco we were in
it was not marrakech family it was some
bit it was the bits
in morocco if you can speak the language
then you're fine
is this the holiday where you said you
went with your stepdad and he had to
take like the
um like the coach to the villa because
it was the cheapest route
yeah it was long the whole thing was
long family it was there so we were in
the
2am yeah and we had like a lady come
round
um the housekeeper where we stayed we
stayed in this really nice house like a
three-story house and the housekeeper
came around one day and made us all
dinner
okay and like she did not speak a word
of english
oh so it was all just awkward gestures
the whole time she was there cooking for
us
it was all just like and then my mom
would try and say something to her
and she obviously didn't understand she
wrote ah
and then just like carry on chopping
carrots and i'm like
this is brutal this is brutal someone
stopped talking to her please
because i don't want to see it anymore
it's just annoying me yeah like it's
annoying that we don't
like no one speaks english and we do not
speak the language it's just like what
are we doing
it's just [ __ ] annoying me and like a
lot of my holiday destinations
have always been based on like there's
places where it can look nice
yeah and i'm like where is that and it's
a place in a country that i've never
heard of and i'm like we're not going
there because i already know that i'm
speaking english
i'm just not dealing with that i'm just
not willing to deal with it yeah um so
definitely i'll pick the languages
that would make my year mm-hmm okay
that's a good answer um i would
definitely pick languages as well i
think it'll be a hard choice though
because i love
the like i would love to know how to
play the drums i'd love to play the
piano
like things like that i would love to
know how to play like the guitar
all those random things but i feel like
the
the amount of languages that there are
outweighs the amount of instruments i'd
want to play anyway yeah yeah yeah i
mean you would be
give it six months you'd be down to the
clarinet and you're like what am i i'm
gonna do it
i'll be down to the triangles like
dinging it is pointless
um so language is for sure for sure like
you said as well
that would um unlimit my travel um
and obviously just being able to jump in
any conversation and
it would just it could because it was
like if a girl was speaking to me in
spanish or italian for example you're
telling that i don't really like i know
verbs and stuff in spanish and i know
like certain things
what certain things mean in like
portuguese but italian i have no clue
what's
what
yeah a lot of things in italian so if
chick was speaking to me in italian and
i just
reboled in italian as well it would gasa
bro you would
gasser bro you know what it reminds me
of what there was one time years ago we
were in uni we went on a night out in
birmingham
okay and there was um was either
probably okay i remember i don't
i don't unfortunately i don't remember
you being there but i remember me being
there i remember toby being there and i
remember aaron being there
so why you wouldn't be there i don't
know i was probably working
maybe true actually you might not have
been there but anyway we went out
and there was this buff buff girl
i definitely wasn't there i remember if
you said i wasn't there buff white girl
right
yeah and um i i went to
i can't remember i think we had like a
little iting
and i was all right and toast is with me
he was giving me the little
god yeah i was like all right man you
know what let me swallow some ego
and then see what do you know i went to
say something to her
and she actually came back and she's
like oh i'm so sorry
my english is not good and i was like
[ __ ] she's like i'm french and i was
like
cool man all right enjoy your night
i went over and um oh well go on how's
that bro she doesn't speak english she's
french
i wasn't there but i think you've told
me this oh i definitely would have told
you oh i told you that night since we
got back
tom's just wrote i was like oh she's
french sweat i was like yeah he is all
right
cool if i'm just stumbled over there
and i was like the [ __ ] is going on bro
mom was church she was just giggling
just giggling just
[Laughter]
what the [ __ ] just happened yeah he was
like i didn't tell you i speak french
i want to knock him out oh i didn't tell
you fight talk
we live in the same yard and you didn't
tell me that you speak french that's
fluent
the fight talk clearly we're not boys
that's what you just told me in french
we're not boys
so um but yeah from then i was like [ __ ]
i wish i spoke
bro [ __ ] i wish i spoke a differently
it's just so
it warms a woman's heart 100 percent she
must have been wet for him
right 100 she was like right this guy
can just actually speak fred just just
can't just switch it up like that
i i actually um applaud
foreigners that come to england and
learn our language i applaud them
so much especially like it doesn't
matter which country you come from
you're following your phone and
obviously you know
english is your first language or if you
go to like any english
english speaking country let me not just
say england america for example
australia for example blah blah blah
um and they just learn our language they
have to work so
many millions of people have done it
year and year out month and month i just
come down here no one from this country
does it
millions and millions and millions of
people have done it england probably
billions
probably billions billions of people
have english speaking
people are probably the most ignorant
people in this world
not even yeah one million percent i'm
not learning another language
it's an effort it's excellent i'm not
doing that
i'm so ignorant i wasn't raised to do
that i'm not learning another like for
what
for what oh there's so much culture out
there that we're missing bro
there's so much everyone learns english
everyone knows we're so ignorant we
expect to fly out there
and i'm vixx if you don't speak my life
yeah it's it's mad isn't it it is mad
it's
madness it's mad it's the way i used to
they probably see it the way i see it
when i watch movies
whenever you watch movies you don't
watch a movie an american movie and
they'll always try and pay
in dollars okay have you ever noticed
that
um american in a movie
like um will always try and pay for
something
in a foreign country in dollars oh in a
foreign country okay okay okay
okay yeah that makes sense they'll go to
china and they'll give them dollars and
[ __ ] and i all grown up i
was for some reason it was such a bug
bear and i used to be like why are they
paying them in dollars
like how [ __ ] disrespectful is that
is that you don't even change up your
money
yeah you just bought your own money and
expected to get away with it are you who
the [ __ ] do you think you are
so ignorant that's how i am going to a
different
country i'm just getting a taxi and i'm
expecting taxi donny to speak english
and i'm i'm annoyed when he doesn't and
he's thinking
i'm just like living my life you came
here you came here and you got in my car
and you're vexed at me
because you're struggling like it's it's
a long time because it is very it's an
angry thing
that's why yeah going back to the
instruments or
um languages it would be such a massive
help such a massive help like that toby
situation like you said just
brought up to a starter speaking french
oh i'll gas so many women
oh i'll gas them and just dip i got
energy for that i just want to speak
i don't want to speak the language i
would i want a kkk
my dad speaks french fluently yeah and
he used to take us to france because my
uncle lives in france
we used to go visit him okay um he lives
in the south south of france is banging
oh i'm not surprised bro it's
hot i am i've never been stuck and there
are women there i'm not surprised
tan of the women in south front is
disgusting we're going for years
yeah marseille we'll do what marseille
um but boy um yeah he used to take us
there he was just chatting
he's chatting brav and i'm like
bro and he would like to talk to someone
and then like what did they say you know
oh they said this but like their
accent's a bit hard to understand and
i'm like
the fact that you can even understand
accents means that you can speak french
that means that you could be actually it
all sounds like gibberish to me
i don't i can't pick up on nothing do
you prefer
do you prefer a spanish
speaking woman speaking to you in
english or a french-speaking woman
speaking to you in english
like in terms of like oh accent-wise
when it comes to like
like sexual talk french french
the french accent is banging
banging fam french a million percent i
can't think of
anything better it's unbelievable
brother
it's unbelievable i'm i'm at a toss
between the two because
i've don't think i've ever [ __ ] a
french guy in my entire life i haven't
but i have [ __ ] a girl that isn't
french
but speaks french that spoke
french english to me whilst we were
[ __ ] i was like oh my god
that's different that doesn't do it for
me you know really when it's not your
native tongue
anything you're doing like how to
explain it i know exactly what you mean
though
the same thing that we said like don't
say daddy to me in an english accent
ask pepe if you're like if you
you like i'm not [ __ ] you good enough
if you can speak
your second language to me in bed you
know what i mean
you've got too much cognitive ability
going on right now that you're trying to
spice it up
with your second lamb you're not lost
yeah you're not lost today i want you to
barely be able to speak english
you know i want you talking tongues to
me
i always spew in hebrew fam aramaic
that's what i want to hear
when we're [ __ ] i don't want you to
to mix up
freestyle in french in english oh that's
hilarious
i'm not [ __ ] good enough i'm upset
i'm hilarious
i've not heard enough french because i i
feel like in this
not necessarily in this day and age um
but where i'm associated
in manchester obviously i see a lot more
spanish people than i do french people
because there's a there's a huge spanish
culture in mani then there is french
job really yeah there's a huge bunch of
cultural money um
it's like spanish clubs spanish tapas
places blah blah there's a lot there's a
lot so
the more people you meet or the more
foreigners you meet either come from
spain or spanish-speaking countries
there's a lot of italians as well a lot
of italians gang there's that i know of
anyway there aren't that many french
people in like my circle or this circle
that i see in the circle that i know so
um that's more time where i'd probably
speak spanish and probably pick spanish
rather in terms of like the sexual
lingo i'd pick spanish because that's
what i'm used to that's what i would
know
yeah you'll get on better here yeah
definitely yeah
i can imagine the french one being top
tier i can imagine i've spoke like i
said i've never dated a french girl or
anything like that
but i remember my um
uncle again when we used to go over to
france my uncle
his missus at the time that he was
seeing
for years whenever we'd go over there i
used to think your accent is buff
i used to think i bet not not even in a
sexual context
i used to think i bet my uncle loves
that accent
and like my uncle um so basically my
uncle my uncle dave
his first name is greg okay but his
middle name is dave but everyone just
calls him dave that's his uncle dave
but she would call him gregory and any
time
he's in the kitchen chopping up some
rattata to you bro
and she'll just be there gregory
to be fair though um i i do know
she's not french but she i think she's
maybe algerian but obviously i think
they speak french
area um so the way she says my name
obviously and it's just that the accent
of it and like the cadence of the voice
is just
it's just sexy french accent does it for
me i've never heard anyone say my name
like that yeah
because i'm not in france i don't know
french people like that and so with the
way she says it is
a french accent does it for me i like
sexy
i never used to like accents but yeah
the french accent has always done it for
me
always i wonder what it's like i wonder
what it's like
for a german-speaking country
to speak sexually in german oh it's
harsh in it i bet it's hard i'm russian
yeah it's harsh i bet it just
it just couldn't have been yeah i
couldn't imagine
yeah that could be wrong yeah that could
be totally wrong but i don't know
that's how i feel about how like
uh german struggle i'm gonna get cussed
for this german
people struggle to sound um
[Music]
feminine in their accent okay as to how
i
feel scouse liverpool guys struggle to
sound masculine
i can't hear a liver a liver puddling an
accent from a a guy
and think you sound like masculine you
can't take him seriously yeah
you haven't got the decibels
do you know what i mean he eat like
he's
[Laughter]
where are your pubes from where are they
where's the base
yeah where's the base it's unfortunate
for them yeah
even if you have a deep voice yeah and
you have a scouse accent
it just raises it yeah and it's just
it's unfortunate in it
it sucks ladies anyone that listens to
this that speaks german or knows how to
speak german or he's from germany or a
german speaking country
please dm me a voice note i mean dead
are serious i know you are sort of
please
please send me a voice note of something
sexy that you would say to a guy whilst
you're in bed
so you can just wi-fi so i can decipher
like first of all what it sounds like
because i have no context
and whether it's sexy to me don't try
don't cuss me out either because
obviously i know i'm not going to
understand what you're saying don't cut
out the thing don't call me one like an
idiot the level of
how do i say it bravado that you have to
be like
send me a voice note in german so i can
decide whether i think it's sexy or not
listen
so you can reply and be like yeah i was
right it's not sexy
she's trying her hardest you know yeah
right it's disgusting i just
i just want to know i know you do i just
wanted for research purposes
that's all it is yeah of course search
i'm intrigued as well if you're french
in spanish it's all sender i'm used to
it but send it
yeah i want to hear it i'm used to it
but send it anyway that's hilarious
german and italian
i'm very intrigued very intrigued that's
what it sounds like because
i've never i know what you mean i've
been blessed with that
right completely off topic yeah go for
it i've got a question like i'm on this
first time thing in a minute okay i keep
thinking about first times
okay um do you remember the first time
you realized you couldn't sing
no that's a great question though but oh
definitely not now
but um
i'm trying to think
nah that's that's it just no i just know
i can't see do you know what i mean
first time this is thing is that this is
leg in life
okay for me okay first time i realized
oh hang on one second sorry guys
yo um i'm just recording my part at the
minute can i call you back
was it important all right
cool i'll call you back
my brother why not um the first time
this is late late late night this was 21
years old
first time i realized i couldn't sing
because i was 21 years old
um and you were there all of us were
there
okay it was in miami okay so we're uh
this is contest right let me paint a
picture
[ __ ] now so all of us are in miami
there's five of us we've spoke about
this story a few times well this trip a
few times
we're all in miami and we're in the ice
cream store there was an ice cream store
in our hotel
right there's an ice cream store in our
hotels this is we were just chilling
i think i know what you're going to tell
me yeah yeah yeah we've never actually
spoken about it
it happened like eight years ago never
spoken about it most awkward situation
that none of us have ever spoken about
that's hilarious and anyone who listens
in this group in our french group anyone
who listens to this spot is going to
laugh because they will all know what
this is about
but none of us said there was an ice
cream thing in our joint
yeah i know exactly right so there was a
day in miami we went in the
in the monsoon season brother it was
raining
raining so there's one rainy day in
miami and we had an ice cream store
inside of our hotel and we were just
chilling there and the guy that worked
behind the counter was really really
uh cool i can't remember her name oh
never uh some short black girl i
remember her
she was funny and she randomly one day
was just like oh i can rap and i sing
kind of thing just talking
yeah and i was like all right we're
going in
so she must have dropped a quick eight
and then she threw
she got a quick eight and then she threw
in some pipes as well yeah
all right cool you you can do what you
said you can do it yeah
and then um obviously jacob's a
professional singer so he's
out there doing it um and needless to
say so i have our
five friends there's me fou had jacob
toby and aaron
jacob toby and aaron are all fantastic
yeah they've got good voices
jacob yes and the rest jacob is a
professional level aaron's got
a surprisingly good voice and so he's
got very surprisingly good toby's just
toby toby's just multi-talented
at everything he's just people in french
and singing he does what he wants he
does what he wants baby does
everything is easy for him he's a wafer
um but anyway so we're in there and
these times
i didn't think i could sang but i
thought i could hold a note yeah yeah
i could hold a note so we've been in
this
uh ice cream store for like two hours
and we're just sitting on one of the
tables and we're chilling
and i think can't remember but we were
just chilling and maybe someone was just
like
yeah it's just a quick
and then ever and then i think jacob was
like all right carry on carry on
currently and he just started
singing one cover of one song ah okay
cool and then he dropped it to aaron
aaron mixed it with a new tune and then
everyone's singing singing singing and i
think they turned to you
and you immediately you cut it off yeah
and you know what i'm not saying that's
not saying i'm not i'm not even gonna
entertain this [ __ ]
i'm not singing i didn't know i bet it
turned to tobes
and then um tobes at this point i don't
even think our new types could sing
okay i think this is the first time i've
ever heard type c um and he just started
singing
and i can't remember what he was singing
and i was like mad like tobes can
actually sing
and then without even realizing i
realized probably like the second before
jacob said it to me and i realized
they're gonna try and make me sing
because you're next i'm next so the
whole circle's been done and i'm next
and then um it came to me and then i was
just there vibing vibing
i think you were on the drums and then
everyone had done their thing and then
uh jay's like
james jump in jump in no i was like
and then he was like no you can you like
i've heard you like you can see right i
don't know what's that stuff
i can't i don't even know what i'm
saying i've got nothing prepared
and then turtles are ah drop a dawn and
i just want to dawn drop miguel that's
your favorite song
my favorite song of all time at that
point oh my god and i was like i can't
even pass up this opportunity
so i just came there
i let my love done babe
little dress you down
you gotta know you gotta know
that and then i could feel my cheeks
getting hot
and i was like yeah and jay was like
cool anyway and then he just he just
took over the whole thing
and from there you know when you just
feel small small and
hot i was thinking it got so hot in here
my armpits were sweating clouds
and i knew everyone was thinking ah
james has nothing oh he has nothing
there's no pipes and i was like wow i
can't sing
and actually have to find out on a
public format that i can't sing
to save my life that's peak it was peak
that's very big i feel like i can hold a
note now
because i s not sing but i sing at home
a lot more because i listen to music
every day yeah
yeah so i feel like i've quote unquote
trained myself because of the longevity
of it
i tried myself to know that like i can
hold a note in that
i know what songs i can and cannot sing
perfect perfect exactly
dawn i can't sing i can't sing
regardless i like the song i can't sing
it
i feel like i can do a lot of brent
feyer's songs because i listened to that
earlier yeah
his voice ranges from like well i don't
even know the [ __ ]
thingies like alto and oh god i don't
know
but yeah yeah i know like low bass type
or whatever it's called but yeah
um so his songs probably a couple of
them was but i can only hold
a note but i could never i can't ever
say fam i'll never say i consider
oh i wish i it was the most humiliating
thing i've ever had i bet it sounds mean
angie i was there but i don't remember
it
i remember that scenario but i don't
remember you actually singing because i
remember
i actually remember when she started
wrapping the chick that works there yeah
and then we started to we were ah we
started to
wrap uh the crew so we were like do
doo doo doo and then you guys were
singing the loving the crew
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah it came to
me to sing like the rap
drake's bit and i remember flopping the
first line and it was like ah
you messed it up bro about that i
remember about that i remember i can't
remember what i
i was wrapped cited and that was i can't
believe it was i think i dropped like a
quick four bar and jay ran out the room
i remember he was like nah
and he ran out of the room like a kid i
think because me and
me and the chick were going back to back
yeah something like that yeah yeah
it was that was funny that was only fair
yeah that was a funny segment of the
trip bro i've never thought about that
till
you just bought that that that moment
sticks out my mind i was like that's
humiliating wow i didn't i've not in
front of all the mans i realized like
right i actually can't sing
that's mad i wonder if bella thinks this
guy needs to shut the [ __ ] up
yeah obviously i sing all the time at
home oh yeah quote unquote i hope
she probably thinks man shut the [ __ ] up
your voice is shocking
i don't care the things i don't of
course you're gonna say regardless but
sometimes i think she this this she must
think like bro
it's quick by your head so that's top
two
there's actually like only a couple
things that are like the most
embarrassing things that happened to me
that's one of them one second i don't
remember that one that much but that's
that must be deep
to be fair actually tell a lie it's not
one of the most embarrassing things
that's ever happened to me
but it sticks out as like i felt so hot
like my skin was on fire i know what you
mean and i was like oh
and i would have preferred it it's i
think what made it more embarrassing is
the fact that like
no one said anything they just they just
carried on them they must have all been
thinking
that was bad damn because i thought this
is terrible
thank the lord i didn't sing oh [ __ ]
thank the lord i know myself
i skipped that nice singing bro i don't
remember skipping myself do you know
what i mean
yeah yeah i remember feeling hot that
time another time
was when i popped in class one time uh
in uni
no no no no this was in school okay in
school
the worst fight i've ever done so i'm
not a big fart guy bruh
i'm just not i'm just literally not a
big fat guy like i'm the kind of guy
that would literally take
measures to make sure that i'm just not
i fighting in front of people
so i remember i was in school
and um do you remember that in the movie
stepbrothers
where they're interviewing in their
tuxedos
and one don lets out a fart fam a [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's so crazy i watched that
brothers last week did you that's crazy
i thought you said that
snow boys he lets out that fart and at
the end then when they're like well go
on why did you do that and i said i
thought it's going to be silent
i said it was not silence mine was like
that
but i thought not that it was silent but
i thought it wasn't going to stink like
that
because especially back then my diet was
clean my dad was clean i wouldn't have
it the fragrance wouldn't be there
it wasn't going to be that deep yeah so
basically
here's what happened so basically this
is the this is
hands down the most embarrassing thing
that's ever happened to me okay bro have
you told me this before no
i don't think i've ever thought anyone
said nobody chest no i've not told
anyone okay it's not something i just
joke lightly about
so i was in english class right i must
have been like yeah
nine or year ten year ten i think i was
in year ten
enrolled in english class and um
sit down and the classes are empty i got
there early so it's maybe like
me sitting here maybe one other person
sitting at the front
and then like my teacher's there and
then the students are about to start the
rest of class is about to start coming
in
but for some reason i got there a couple
minutes early so i'm sitting there my
belly's doing bits
my bed is doing bits fam that's freaking
i need to pop so i'm just chilling i'm
thinking bruh no one's here
so i just let out a quick little just a
quick one
and i thought it was going to be the end
of it fam sat down
and i'm just getting my books and stuff
together and i just get
i catch with it i was like the breeze of
the books
blew the opening in the it just raised
it up and i got a whiff and i was like
oh my god
when the fart is 10 times worse than you
expect no joke it's not like a stink
bomb you know what people used to set
off stink bombs yes
oh they were the worst eggy fam the ting
was eggy and i was like
that doesn't smell like it came out of
me and i was like oh my god oh my god oh
my god that's bad
it's back that's bad and then my boy
came and sat next to me
and he's like [ __ ] hell bruh what's
that and i was like ah
and he's he was nasty anyway he's a
white guy called adam he was nasty
anyway
in a sense of just like he was like he's
about fighting okay okay
okay he's one of those white rugby
dancers he don't give a [ __ ] about
anything he'll get his dick out and he's
cool
so he said i was like what the [ __ ] is
that yeah and i was like bro
big my thing i fired i didn't know i was
gonna sing that bad yeah and he was he
was like jesus christ bro it stinks
and i was like
so we sit there and then we're just
chilling chilling chilling and another
guy i know
uh she was a friend of mine called alex
she sat in front of me and she sat down
and she's getting her books ready she's
up
she's up oh oh my god like and she
screams she's like
nah nah everyone someone set off a sleep
bomb and uh
my face is like blood red and i'm like
i'm
breathing like oh please god please
please please allow it i'll allow it and
alex was like
that stinks that stinks right now what
the [ __ ] and i'm like
yeah yeah it does i'm thinking ah that
does stink
my boy
bus through me threw me directly under
the bus
no way man's like yeah james fighted
and she's like what and i was like nah
no no no no
and she's like nah did you fart and then
he's like yeah
yeah he's fine it smells like stink bomb
in it broth
she's like yeah she goes nuts like she's
actually angry yeah
james that [ __ ] stinks that james
that's disgusting like what you be
eating like your belly's dirty
everyone else in the class nah james
you're [ __ ] disgusting like nah nah
nah
my boy is howling adam is howling
alex is vexed my teacher's like guys
calm down calm down
it's natural it's only a fart
from my school uniform was crippling i
was there i stopped
i wanted the world to swallow you i've
never been so embarrassed in my life i
never felt so hot and even after the the
fiasco settled down
you still had the ambience of it and i
was just trying to write in my book
and i'm just shaking and you can't get
over it ptsd on the spot bro i wanted
the whole day
over with people just looking at you
like
yeah your your battery hole's nasty bruv
you have to wait for everyone to leave
the class when the class is done before
you leave you can't go out first
you can go out in the mix of people oh
that's a nice it's so bad that like
you imagine yourself standing up and
then you just got like a green patch on
your body
on the on on your school trousers you
know what i mean i think that's how
embarrassing this thing is is that like
i feel if i stand up and was to go out
there's like [ __ ] all over you there'll
be [ __ ] [ __ ] all over the body all over
the seat
just to give them even more fuel to
ridicule me
oh bro it was awful oh
that's the number one most embarrassing
thing has ever happened damn she was
like you stink bruv
it made me think of a time when i think
i was in year eight or
nine um i don't it's similar to you but
it wasn't as embarrassing
because there wasn't people around me
but all i remember is i needed to [ __ ]
i was in school and i don't know why
it was one of them ones where you know
when the shit's worse than what you
think
so you go to the toilet or prepare but
once you start it just doesn't
you know then ones where you're pushing
but it's straining you to push you i
felt like i was giving birth
basically yeah yeah yeah well i like you
know just screaming oh
damn ones and i think maybe i had food
poisoning on a site because i remember
going to
um we've got a thing called a matron do
you know what a matron is no so matron
is a person or a male or female i
believe i can think it can be both sexes
in the term anyway is like a nurse that
works in like the boarding house area or
like works in
works in a school but her title i
believe is called a matron
um so i went to her office unbeknownst
to me
my eyes were bloodshot right oh my god
bloodshot you were
straining bloodshot ran and as soon as i
walked in i can't remember what i walked
in for i'm assuming i was ill or
something i
don't know and she was like have you
been smoking
and i was like what do you mean have i
been smoking like i've come in here for
x one's out of comment where i came
before yeah
and she's asking me off the bat like
you've been smoking your eyes are bloody
red like why but what have you been
doing kind of things like nah i've not
been smoking i'm i'm
straining i don't even know if i even
thought that i've been [ __ ]
yeah but because obviously i didn't know
my eyes were bloodshot but i could
feel like i was i could i was like this
you know my eyes were
partially closed when i was talking to
her because the strain
i don't know what was coming out of me
that day but yeah she just assumed off
the bat that i was smoking in this day
i was just like oh damn it must be it
must look bad oh
foreign because i can't even think of my
that that's the first thing that came to
most embarrassing thing because i've
said to you before and i've said it on
here many times i'm a very consequential
thinker
so i try not to put myself in a
situation where i have to try and defend
myself
i just rather not do it so i don't know
what my thing is
i didn't know myself i didn't know i was
going to have to go through that and the
thing is is
you can't in that situation you can't
retaliate of course not you have to kind
of
try and laugh i couldn't laugh i also
said
[Laughter]
i'll give you stink you [ __ ] take a
look at you you're ugly cuz
you're ugly and you over there why are
you laughing improv your breath smells
like my body
i want to go off on everyone but if you
could do that you sort of make matter
worse long for you they're going to gang
up
the worst ones are you said you were
well there was only a couple people in
the class when it happened then
obviously people
yeah yeah yes i hate when that happens
you think you're scot-free
i was fast free and then people just
like come in and people are walking past
you from everywhere
and she's like oh and they know it's you
oh they know they know it's you they
know it's you
the what irks me the most
in like work for example or like a
public a public um
place i've got public toilets and stuff
when you go in and it's probably the
only toilet that's there
let's see you take a piss in a toilet in
the cubicle as opposed to the
urinal but someone has just chat before
you
go for a piss and then you come out and
see like three men waiting everyone
thinks it's you
it's that big man you just want to
explain yourself you want to be like
just so you know there was a [ __ ] in
there when i came in here it wasn't me
it was there but you just look at it
i think about it i think why even
contemplating this because they're going
to obviously
think it's well i sound like i [ __ ]
hate that i hate when i
[ __ ] hate that because you think [ __ ]
it no one's gonna clock me going in
there so i'm gonna quickly piss and dip
up five mana just there chilling waiting
for it
i'm like oh these men are gonna think
i'm disgusting
these men are gonna think i'm disgusted
right
worse feeling it's one of the worst
feelings i'm like [ __ ] sake i hate
that bro i absolutely hate that it's
[ __ ] nightmare
i actually [ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
nightmare
oh that's not me angry thing because
that actually resonates with me is that
terrible it's happening
especially ladies as well if you share
it not share with your ladies and stuff
ladies try and i'm assuming like to be
clean and blah blah blah proper but
probably ladies are the worst though
especially blowing up the toilet yes
especially when they when they're drunk
obviously because i work in hospitality
scared scattered scattered
it's a it's a it's a dark image i've
obviously never seen it
it's a dark image oh and now women don't
[ __ ] bro i refuse to believe it they
can't [ __ ]
women can't [ __ ] that's dirty
that's disgusting am i the [ __ ] um
well you've got something before that no
i haven't do you want to do that
thingies oh the fan requests yeah
yeah we'll do that instead uh where are
you
so hey guys i have a question for you
two
my man and i have always had good sex
hat my man and i have always had a good
sex life
but recently i noticed he doesn't stay
hard when we have sex i also notice
sometimes when i give him i also notice
it sometimes when i give him head
i haven't done anything different in
terms of technique i haven't changed an
appearance
and there's no personal hygiene issue i
ask him if there's anything he wants me
to do that i don't
he says no and that he's extremely happy
with our sex
he told me in the past that i give him
the best head he's ever had
and that our sex is i quote explosive
lol and not to sound cocky but i am told
by everyone i've been with
that i'm the best head that they've ever
had and the best sex also so i have a
hard time
thinking that it's me that's the problem
i have directly asked him about it
i've directly asked him about the issue
about getting soft because i don't want
to emasculate him
what do you guys think could be going on
could he
maybe not be attracted to me anymore so
just quick recap
um couple apparently their sex has been
great she's noticed that
he's not staying hard whilst they're
[ __ ] and also when she tries to give
him head as well
um she's outrightly asked him is there
something wrong with me is it my parents
is it my hygiene what can i do what can
i change
he said nothing she's been told that by
multiple sources and multiple exes in
the past that
she gives the best head and their sex is
banging um
she doesn't want to emasculate him and
so what does she think is going on and
what should she do
cool man for me
the first thing that popped in my head
on this one
was like one of two things
one potentially there could be too much
routine to it
because i've told you before i'm i hate
routine sex betty by time sex it's not
for me
buddy buy time set and the thing is as
well like technique your technique can
be flawless
but if it's predictable then i'm not
horny anymore
okay like if if like you could give like
i said you can give the best head of all
time
but if i know what your moves are and i
know like okay
cool so we're gonna go to bed we're
gonna watch tv for five minutes
we're gonna roll over lips each other
she's then gonna
do this thing where she puts her hand on
my chest lays me flat um
pulls the covers over her head down
shimmers down
and then gives me the slops like
regardless if your technique's good like
if i know that's gonna happen
and then we're gonna [ __ ] like it
doesn't matter if you're the best head
ever
because it's just like this is not a
turn-on it's all about what's to turn on
or not it doesn't matter if you're
good so it's all about what's a turn-on
and like
for me it yeah it doesn't
yeah the technique may not be the issue
and like it could just be and granted he
said you asked him like oh is there
anything i can do to mix it up
he also if it is a case of like he does
want something different he's not going
to teach him he will never tell you
probably because
that also is a turn off yeah so i have
to ask for something different because
it's like
if you tell me oh yeah you know what i
actually want you
to dress up as oh like i actually want
you to do this
this will be a tunnel for me the next
time she does it knowing that she's only
doing it because you asked her to do it
is a slightly more turn off yeah because
it's not it's pre-ordained it's not
yeah yeah yeah it's not it's not why
it's not who she's yeah it's not who you
are it's the same thing as well it's
like
we've had discussions about before about
girls not liking giving head
okay and it's like if you don't like
obviously i would never be with a girl
who doesn't give head
that's a fact i'm laughing because it's
true like
i'm saying never but i've never actually
yeah yeah yeah but i'm never going to be
with a girl that doesn't give head i
don't but if i find myself in a
situation where i was with a girl who
doesn't give head
if i know she doesn't like it i'm not
going to let her give me a head yeah do
you know me because
you know it's just not going to bang
yeah it's not going to if i know she
doesn't give head and then all of a
sudden on my birthday she tries to give
me a head i'm going to be like yuck stop
stop stop
this isn't you yeah like this is not
going to turn me on because i just know
you're forcing it
like a guy wants head from a girl who
wants nothing but
who would text him say i want to come
round choke on your dick and then go
home i don't even want you to fight me i
just want some dick in my mouth
that's what a guy wants so like it
sounded like for me potentially
like this this woman like they could
have a great relationship
and they could [ __ ] all the time but it
could be even if it's not
massively routine he could be in the
routine of it a bit much
and he doesn't want to say oh i want to
mix it up he doesn't he just might want
a nasty [ __ ]
he might want a filthy [ __ ] he may even
be about who's hot who gives the best
sex
he just might want a filthy [ __ ] um
kanye west said it best in
[Music]
what song was it
he said something like um even if i've
got
even if i've got like he says i'm like
naomi campbell i'd still want
his stormy daniels even which song was
that in
even if you've got naomi campbell i
still might want me to stormy daniels
and i'll keep going but i have to find
it yeah but do you get the reference i
know what you mean yeah
um but like yeah like
it's not necessarily about her as a
person yeah it just maybe
something else might turn him on and
it's not even like
a case of like um we've said this before
in that i feel like women might find it
hard to wrap their head around
why would a guy would cheat sometimes
because a
girl would less likely cheat on a guy
with a guy who's uglier than her man
yes always a lower level of her man
because
women are attracted to hierarchy they
want the top
guy so it's more is if they're gonna
cheat you're gonna cheat on someone who
is in some way better than your guy a
guy will just [ __ ] a girl
just because yeah just see just because
you know she's nasty
yeah like sometimes that's just men want
men just want nasty and it's not yeah
it's not even about the girl
it's never it's just like and women were
like oh why would he cheer me with her
like look at her she's disgusting
i used to go i used to have like i used
to actually have quite a few female
friends
and it sucks i don't have that many
female friends anymore but like i'd go
around the house and they'd mana cheated
on my stuff like that and i'd find them
on the girls [ __ ] facebook page
that's scoring for everything just like
james do you think that's attractive do
you think that's attractive i'm not a
big man it's not a battle it's not a
fact it's not about the girl
yeah it's just about the moment that
mouth
that's the nastiest mouth i've seen in a
minute what are we talking about what
i'm going to want to slide my dedication
he wanted to not that's why
she's talking trash that's all it is
yeah so i would
she he he might just want something
unexpected from her yeah
like in if in order to spice it up i
don't think you can really
say i don't think you can really ask him
to find
out he just might want something nasty
something completely different
i mean maybe throw anal on the table who
knows
maybe you do ain't already maybe just
maybe it's maybe it might just be
something about the demeanor
maybe he wants to feel like you need
the dick to survive do you know what i
mean
maybe feel like maybe he maybe it might
be a case of like sometimes i don't
necessarily like it
if a girl like i'm attracted to a girl
who's out to get the nut for her
all right yeah like i said when i said
like i i like to please in sex yeah
so if i feel like a girl's doing the
most for my benefit
obviously it's lovely but it's not like
a massive turn off yeah
like like um like we've said before when
we said before about like um
we were just on uh before we started
this um this this episode we were just
on
uh instagram if we had scrolled across a
page of some
uh woman she's talking about like ah
just get your man
just message your guy this christmas
just message a guy this christmas or
whatever
and tell him to um come round eat your
[ __ ]
and dip yeah and i was like brother i
would do that i would do that
without if i was seeing if i was seeing
a girl and she said bro get your ass
over here you're not [ __ ] me i just
want you to eat my [ __ ] i want my nut
and i want you to go
that's a turn on because yeah a guy
wants to feel like
it's just sex it's just about the nut
it's just about the nut and then like if
i feel like you're doing the most for my
benefit and you're not really here for
yourself yeah
sometimes it's just a bit like yeah you
need to be as honest as i am
for yourself do you know yourself like
the same way like you said i'm i'm a
pleaser as well
and i would love a girl to give me i
always want girls to give me head for
their benefit
yeah the same way i eat out because i
want to eat out for me
regardless of whether it pleases you or
not which i'm sure it does but i do it
for me
so yeah i don't really do it for them
maybe mix it up in a way of maybe when
you're when donnie comes home from work
sit on the sofa hike the skirt up
and just play with yourself play with
yourself tell him big mike get on your
knees and just eat me
get on your knees i'm trying to change
his perspective on life get on your
knees i'm trying to nut
that could never happen to me i can
never come home from a busy day of work
and my missus is just there [ __ ]
boob tube skirt on no underwear
high socks high socks i love a high
socks i don't know why who doesn't
just legs spread out on the sofa just
playing with the [ __ ]
bro she says get out of here get on your
knees come eat this come suck this
vagina from because i
want to not and then you should carry on
carrying your day there's food in the
microwave
oh i'll be so hungry
try it out and tell me i was so hard
imagine if you told me you're actually
not gonna [ __ ] me
you gotta play minor games with donnie
it's a power play i know you got to do
the power play
you're not fighting what's that movie
called uh
the wolf of wall street emily united
crap use misses oh where she's
using the [ __ ] thing that is one of the
sexiest things
he was dying to [ __ ] he was dying to
[ __ ] up dying
to [ __ ] it that kind of power play is
the sexiest thing
it is it's all about the control and the
balance of it you have to be
dominant as well as submissive yeah when
a woman is confidently dominant
it takes my breath away oh bro it takes
my breath away because yeah
that's my advice from them that's my
advice
drop the power play don't touch his dick
don't go near his dick he don't he
doesn't deserve the first time i'm
getting to eat you out
no and intend to go to sleep tell him to
do what he's doing do you say thank you
for that i needed that hurry on with you
say thank you i needed that and then
just get on with your day he'll be
solid his mind will do back flips he
might be praying to [ __ ] you
praying oh please do that let us know
how he goes yeah yeah shout out
once it's done please do that that's how
it goes
oh no one could do that to me i could
never walk into an establishment
and my yacht is just there just playing
with it oh i lose my i drop everything
i drop everything is getting launched
shopping everything i drop it all
i drop everything yeah gee that power
play will bang
i would scurry to let you know when
you're like
ah we'd have to [ __ ] it's done oh i'm
getting a hot population thinking about
it yeah bro do that
yeah jesus that's how we're gonna wrap
up the episode do that let us know how
it goes i promise you it will work
i promise you it will work it has to
it has to yeah if it doesn't work i'm
sorry get a new relationship yeah
because
he's he's he's a robot clearly yeah yeah
that would drive me insane yeah yeah
that would i'd lose the plot
yeah it's all about the property
sometimes women you need to just be
dominant just be about yourself be about
yourself dominant but confident yeah
command the [ __ ]
yeah as much as a guy loves like to feel
nurtured and loved and stuff like that
sometimes yeah he needs to know that
you're your own person and you're out
for your own
interest as well not not like not at his
expense
but you're out for your own nuts you're
out for your own interest you're out for
your own money you're
you're out for yourself it's a turn-on
it's a turn-on because the amount of
guys that would probably ask their girls
to just give them
because they want head is a norm do you
know what i mean whereas the vice versa
women don't say that women don't say it
often and it's eternal when they do
i've never been if a woman ever told me
come through i just want you to eat my
box
oh i'll eat this salivate eat this
you're not [ __ ] i don't want your
dick but i would
salivate i don't want your dick just
come i'm trying to nut like you said
i'll tell donny to floor it i'll tell
donny to i have to be there in the next
five minutes
because you have to be the asap she
can't continue this momentum for 10-15
minutes
do you know what i mean it's about it's
all about the moment yeah it's calm do
you alright you man
[Music]
you